John 7, here's the thing. Here's the
objection brought by Zena. John 7:es
1-10. After this, Jesus went around in
Galilee, he did not want to go about in
Judea because the Jewish leaders there
were looking for a way to kill him. But
when the Jewish festival of tabernacles
was near, Jesus's brothers said to him,
"Leave Galilee and go to Judea so that
your disciples there may see the works
you do." No one who wants to become a
public public
figure acts in secret. Since you are
doing these things, show yourself to the
world. For even his own brothers and not
believe in him. Therefore, Jesus told
them, now here's the objection. My time
is not yet here. For you any time will
do. The world cannot hate
you. The world cannot hate you. But it
hates me because I testify its works are
evil. Now, here's the objection, guys.
It's an objection raised by
Muslims,
anti-Christians of various stripes who
don't believe Jesus is sinless, let
alone God in the flesh. You go to the
festival. I am not going up to this
festival because my time has not yet
fully come. After he had said this, he
stayed in Galilee. Now, here's the
question.
However, after his brothers had left for
the festival, he went also, not
publicly, but in secret.
Ah, we got a problem. Houston, we got a
problem. Jesus said in verse 8, you guys
go up to the festival. I'm not going to
the festival because my time has not yet
fully come. But then in 10 says, when
his brothers did go up to the festival,
Jesus then went up secretly, not
publicly. So she heard, and she's not
the only one, a Christian saying, a
Christian, mind you, saying, "Here Jesus
lie to save himself." Was that true,
Zena? Is that what you heard? Cuz he
said, "I'm not going up. You go up."
They went up. And he did go up secretly,
not
publicly. Therefore, you got a
contradiction. Therefore, Jesus lied.
Therefore, the sinless, holy, pure son
of God lied to save himself. Blasphemy.
And yet, this came from the mouth of a
Christian. I don't know what Christian
would say that, but she heard him. She's
not the only one. So, I'm going to
answer this. I want you to meditate on
how you would answer this. Are you guys
ready for me to go in depth? Thank our
sister Zena for bringing this up. I'm
addressing it again. So, there are two
issues with John 7. Now, he's going to
open it up. Do John 7:8 because I'm
going to show you
something. I'm going to show you a
feature, guys. Biblegateway.com. Thank
the Lord for all these modern resources
that are free. Just pay for an internet.
Now, here's what you're going to do. You
see those two like they look like
phones? You see where it says John 7?
Yeah. Okay. Click on it. It's going to
give you a parallel Bible. Scroll down.
Let's see what Bible gave you. Okay.
King James. Beautiful. The two
bestselling Bibles in the world. Two
bestselling Bibles in the world. NIV,
King James Version. They've done
studies. The King James Bible with the
NIV are the bestselling Bibles in the
Englishspeaking world. This is a fact.
More King James Bibles and NIVs are sold
all over the world among those who read
English. Now watch here. Look at the
NIV. You go to the festival. I am not
going up to this festival because my
time has not yet fully come. Now you see
there's a bracket and an A. Don't click
on it because it's going to indicate
something. Now look to the
right. Go ye up unto this feast. I go
not up yet. You see that, Zena? I go up.
I go not up
yet unto this feast, for my time is not
yet full come. So in the majority of the
Greek copies and some very early
witnesses that word yet is in John 7:8.
Some of the early copies don't have it.
But the NIV has a note as one brother
already signified in the comment
section. You see the bracket? It's a
bracket and a click on that A. Look what
it
says. Some manuscripts have not yet.
Some manuscripts not yet. So the NIV is
indicating there are some early Greek
copies that are important witnesses that
have the words not yet. The majority of
the Greek copies of John 7, the majority
of the 5,300 plus have these words or
the word rendered as not yet. So now
let's look at the textual data. Now what
I want you to do
is X out one of the translations. X them
out. So I want to thank you brother. You
really are helping me honestly. You
come, you come at the perfect time. Now,
what I want you to do is where it says
King James version, go to the
NE. NE. See why this guy is a blessing,
guys? Him and prophet Google. I pray for
them because you see how easy he makes
it for me. Now, here the New English
translation has a note. You go up to the
feast yourselves. I'm not going up to
the feast. Now, when we look at their
note B, scroll down. It gives you a
lengthy note on the textual data. Here
it is. B John 7:8. Let's read it, guys.
Here it goes. Go to the B. John 78.
Scroll down a little more. Right there.
Scroll. You see that? C TC. When you see
the words TC, that means textual
critical note. It's a note on the
manuscripts that affect the meaning of
the verse. Now, notice what it says.
Most
manuscripts most manuscripts
P6675 and then it gives you the list of
the manuscripts and their names. B
LTW, right? Epsilon and I think the
Theta Epsilon manuscript number
07015 0250 F1 13 including most of the
better witnesses have not
yet. Did you guys catch it? Now, Zena,
everyone else, I want you to see the
letter P and the number
6675.
P6675. Those are the two oldest Greek
copies of the Gospel of John. These are
the two Greek copies that even James
White swears by to argue that John 1:18
originally reads only begotten God. So,
you guys seeing it? P66, P75 are the two
oldest Greek copies of John that we have
that contain John 7, right? The oldest
surviving copies that contain John 18
and John 7. And here, Zena, everyone
else, let me know, Zena, if you're
getting it because it was your question.
It has the words not
yet. I do not go up yet.
So
the majority of copies, some of our most
important witnesses in John 7:8 have
that wordo, which in English means not
yet. You go up, I do not go up yet. So
if we go with the evidence, there's no
problem because Jesus said, "You go up.
I'm not going up
yet." That solves the problem. Okay,
everyone with me there? But now let's
read the rest of it. the because these
translators they
prioritize the earlier papyrite
witnesses and they don't give as much
weight to the later Greek copies though
they are in the majority they follow
what they call reason eclecticism they
don't follow the Byzantine textual
tradition which is the majority of the
Greek copies of the New Testament book
books because they're later in time our
oldest copies that contain John 18 and
John 7
6675 have the words as well.
So now these scholars are like okay this
is the evidence this evidence shows okay
these are original to what John wrote
and what Jesus said so then why does the
NE admit it why does NIV omit it here's
their reason here's why they omitt it
guys listen those with the reading are
not as impressive means I don't go up I
don't I go up not I don't go up they're
not Not as imp. No, it's many. That
reading is not as
impressive. The one that says not yet,
that's impressive. The manuscripts that
have, they're impressive. The one that
says, "I don't go up. I don't go up."
Or, "I go up." Not, not as impressive.
But the reading that says, "I don't go
up yet. I go up not yet." That is
impressive. They're admitting it, right?
You're reading it. But oo is the most
more difficult reading here especially
because it stands in tension with verse
10 where he does go up. On the other
hand, it is possible
that arose because of a homoy homo
homo meaning a confusion of letters. A
copist who saw wrote ooke. That probably
why you have in some manuscripts the
word uk. I go up not as opposed to I go
up not yet because someone may have
misread for uking for the variant
reading. However, it is more likely that
now notice what they say here. Look what
they say was introduced early on to
harmonize with what is said two verses
later. Did you guys catch it? They're
admitting the word upo. Not yet. Early.
It's in some of the earliest copies and
it's in the majority of our witnesses.
And the two oldest copies that I'm aware
of that have John 78, P66, right? And
P75 have I go up? Not yet. So, they're
admitting it's early, but you know what?
It may be a scribe early on changed uk
to upo because he wanted it to harmonize
with John 7:10. See what they're
doing. As for Jesus's refusal to go up
to the feast in verse 8, the statement
does not
preclude action of a different kind at a
later point. So even though they don't
accept not yet, they go with the
reading. I go up. I go up. Not I do not
go up. They're still telling you there's
no problem. There's no contradiction.
There's no lie because Jesus is saying
he's not going to go up a certain way
publicly in public procession. Because
when they went to the feast of
tabernacles, people went into groups.
They went up publicly together, which is
what Jesus said he will not do. There is
no contradiction because Jesus's
brothers are asking him to go up
publicly with them in public procession
to make himself seen to the public
crowd. It's in that sense he's not going
up. That's why he went up secretly
discreetly. Where's the contradiction?
Where's the lie? But let me continue.
Okay. And they admitted, look, as for
Jesus's refusal to go up to the feast in
verse eight, the statement does not
preclude exclude action of a different
kind at a later point. Jesus may simply
have been refusing to accompany his
brothers with the rest of the group of
pilgrims, preferring to travel it
separately and in secret with his
disciples.